michel gien c'est bien je ne suis pas le
lourd déficit baraka
alors
[Musique]
tu sais pas
parce que j'ai débuté comme on perd en
trio
[Musique]
et qu'ils étaient deux
montez les escaliers
[Musique]
c'est mon mini show
celui de marseille
j
vous pouvez gagner aussi facilement
tombé
c'est l'histoire de quatre femmes qui se
retrouvent un soir de fête dans un bar à
saint denis elles se sont rencontrées
dans un groupe de parole chacune a connu
l'inceste
moi c'était dans les bois
et l'après midi
mon père n'était pas méchant on y était
plutôt gentil attentionné
il a donc dû cul mais règle
[Musique]
il disait que coucher avec sa fille
c'est comme apprendre à son fils âgé au
foot
il disait qu'il est papa devrait le
faire
je sais bien maintenant la pièce
s'intitule quelque chose
elle a été créée à l'origine à paris par
capucine maillard qui en signe
aujourd'hui l'adaptation réunionnaise
sur un texte de dominique carrère suis
incapable d'être mère faudrait que je
l'enfant'' avant pareil soumis ni n est
pas moi même mais ne m'y connais pas
comment il fait comment il fait
comment on fait
madame maillot franchement c'est la
docteure visnelda 12,1 qui a eu l'idée
de réaliser cette adaptation théâtrale
niveau depuis 20 ans cette psychiatre de
l'établissement public de santé mentale
reçoit dans son cabinet des victimes de
violence à cette fouille n'avait
envisagé aujourd'hui elle reçoit
isabelle qui a été violée à l'âge de 4
ans il pendant deux ans sur un de ses
grands frères vous avez le courage car
votre frère vous a violé et vous avez
détruit votre famille je dis non
ma famille elle était bel et bien
détruite depuis des années c'est une
chose très importante
vous voyez ce que je disais quand
l'inceste quand l'acte incestueux et
quand les actes incestueux et quand
l'inceste entre dans une famille alors
ce que c'est que ce n'est plus une
famille jarnac l'histoire d'isabelle
trouve une autre résonance dans la pièce
que les comédiennes sont en train de
répéter à la cité des arts
ok avec le personnage de vic qui imagine
comment elle pourrait parler de ce que
son frère a bien fait subir
papa mona piano jazz hot
et je fais quoi j'attaque à l'apéro
j'attends des cerfs ou noël tiens oui
noël c'est bien ça noël c'est bien pour
détruire sa famille c'est génial je peux
pas dire ça je peux pas le dire parce
que mon frère il n'a pas été dégueulasse
tout seul qu'est ce que je fais sur me
demande si j'étais d'accord
j'explique que je savais pas que je
pouvais dire non que je croyais que
c'était de ma faute
là pour toi et gigote pas trop parce que
c'est hyper important tu vois bon là
tout ce problème là
de la culpabilité parce qu'on n'a pas
dit non parce qu'on était des gamins
parce qu'on savait pas qu'on pouvait
dire non
mais n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui même si
j'ai 20 ans même si j'ai 30 ans même si
j'en ai 50
j'ai toujours cette difficulté là quand
même l'absurdité du monde les violences
sexuelles les viols c'est le seul truc
où les victimes se sentent coupables
après les viols de son renforcement
la petite isabelle elle a été internée
en hôpital psychiatrique
entre six et huit ans pourquoi mon frère
m'a fait simplement pourquoi surmaturité
de folles ou si on me disait tu te rends
compte
tu sais pourquoi aujourd'hui on a misé
dans cet hôpital parce que tu es folle
pendant toute mon adolescence mon
enfance mon adolescence
le clae soins se sont retournés comme
comme retourner contre vous
comme si vous étiez folle qui avait
fallu exactement est tout à fait reprend
je peux pas lui dire je peux pas le dire
je peux pas le dire la chaleur plus
puissamment hockey vas-y je peux pas à
le dire oui
keith à isa quoi - et puis mon frère je
fais ma vie mon frère les mariés lina's
enfants thé mia malice à mon frère ça
mais gagne pas dit ça je peux pas je
ferais je lui en veux plus je vais
pardonner et quand je le croise dans la
rue on se regarde je ne lui en veux pas
parce que je me dis que lui aussi il a
été victime ce que vous êtes en train de
décrire c'est c'est une famille où c'est
en boucle sans fin
il est tout à fait et si vous vous êtes
celle qui appuie sur l'interrupteur pour
10 pour dire stop
en fait vous détruisez pas vous donner
une chance de revêtement tout à fait mon
meilleur noël comme mon frère était pas
là
et pour que d'autres jeunes aient la
chance de se reconstruire des ateliers
de théâtre forum seront proposés aux
lycéens qui auront vu la pièce quelque
chose sous forme de saynètes jouées par
des élèves parce qu'il touche
touche rouge
les histoires jouer sur scène tourne
toujours autour de la difficulté de
parler de l'inceste et l'objectif est
qu'en assistant à ces représentations
les jeunes se décide par exemple à aller
voir l'infirmière scolaire de
l'établissement
en espérant qu'elle soit un peu plus
compréhensifs que celle de la saynète
répéter ce soir je vois dans ton dossier
que tu viens souvent le lundi matin pour
des problèmes de maux de ventre tu as
mal au ventre là quand ils sont mal au
ventre tamala sur le côté en bas malou
et j'ai mal la cera beaucoup l'enjeu de
ce projet c'est vraiment de rapprocher
le plus possible les ados qui pourraient
en avoir besoin
des dispositifs d'accompagnement et puis
aussi qu'il prenne confiance dans cette
aide
qu'ils sachent qu'elles existent qu'ils
sachent qu'elle est gratuite qu'ils
sachent que c'est pour eux qu'il ya de
la bienveillance qu'on peut les croire
et c'est excitant c'est vraiment ça
l'enjeu
[Musique]
on sait qu'il faut en moyenne 16 ans
pour que la victime d'un inceste ou
commence à en parler avec cette pièce où
l'on pleure et où l'on rit les porteurs
de ce projet espère réduire ce temps
libéré la parole des victimes
[Musique]